Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Oggi faremo
secondo me una delle merende più buone al
mondo, più facili, più veloci, quella che
mi dimentico di fare due mesi prima all'interno del fico. Del fico. Quindi solitamente
quando mi serve tiro fuori la ricotta,
perché ho il latte ottimo per fare la
pizza fritta napoletana, pessimo per
fare le "Crepes"
Ho deciso per questo video di seguire la
ricetta di Chef Stefano Barbato, ma
aggiungerci diciamo un tocco mio perché?
Perché non sono uno Chef e soprattutto
Come no. (Chef Rico) No? Si. Chef Wilhelm?
Io vorrei provare a vedere se si possono
fare all'interno della macchina più bella
che sia mai stata creata dall'uomo e
sto parlando del microonde.
Non lo so perché mi sento che
non è, cioè verrà tutto bene e poi il
microonde ce la piazzerà come sempre
su per la crepes, una bella nutellata. Per
fare queste crepes che di base potrete
utilizzare sia per fare roba dolce o
roba salata, avrete bisogno di due uova
farina, sale, burro, latte che non sia
scaduto, Nutella
Io riesco a sentirne l'odore attraverso questa roba metallica. Non abbiamo una prolunga
Non abbiamo le competenze (Chef Rico)
Prendilo, prendilo al volo. Il primo ingrediente è qui, scusate ci metto questo sopra che almeno blocchiamo i germi
Prima però di metterci a lavoro è
essenziale indossare gli abiti del
mestiere.
Ok. Dopo aver preso il primo ingrediente
fondamentale che sono i bacilli di
Enrico, mettete subito due uova
Ueeelà
Sono stanco di fingere di non essere
all'altezza
Prendiamo il sale, aggiungiamo...mamma mia,
quanto sale c'è qua dentro. Un pizzico di
sale. Shaka laka la. Praticamente sono 100 g di
farina ma ne mettiamo 50 e 50. Cinguanda e cinquanda.
Oddio santo la farina è fatta per
sporcare sempre. Questo momento catartico,
il momento del grammo
Oddio santo, vebbè, vabbè, poteva andare peggio. Iniziamo
Yes. Prima, seconda, terza, quarta, quinta, sesta.
Appena arriva la sesta hai più o meno miscelato
tutto quanto. A questo punto, mentre
tenete co...fra i vostri seni altri 50. Stiamo
iniziando già a sporcare troppa roba per
delle crepes posso dirlo?
C'è da dire che quando fai errori la butti sempre sul collettivo e quando invece va bene..(Chef Rico)
Siamo una squadra. Ho sbagliato tutto. Come
si chiama questo. Non lo usate. Ma perché? (Chef Rico)
Perché i grandi ammettono i loro errori.
Tutta quella farina ha creato sto mappazzone
infinito. Una spatola dai, cioè
beh che ce fa quello con una spatola
effettivamente. Usa la cosa felice. (Chef Rico)
No perché si incastra in mezzo agli occhi
Userò questa. Se fate così non dovrebbero
venirvi grumi. Come facciamo a
controllare i millilitri. Ecco come
dovresti fare. (Chef Mario) La differenza devo fare
La differenza? (Chef Mario)
Spiegaglielo, non ho tempo per lui. Tu devi
arrivare a? (Chef Rico). 400 per aggiungerci 250
millilitri di latte. Secondo me è un'ottima
teoria( Rico). Io non so d'accordo (Mario)
Ma ragazzi, ma quando mai abbiamo fatto le le, ma già è tanto che non ho fatto così "yeee"
Dai forse funziona (Chef Mario)
Ah adesso forse funziona? Ehh. Molto liquido
No no Gu è fallimentare (Chef Rico)
Bah ragazzi giusto un tocchettino eh.
*linguaggio incomprensibile*. Scusami Chef Stefano tra parentesi. Chef Simone. La mia ricetta
richiede una densità maggiore. Una noce
di burro, che noi metteremo adesso
velocemente al microonde. Chi se lo
sarebbe mai aspettato
Non mi ricordo mai come funziona questo. Lasciarlo riposare almeno 20 minuti (Chef Stefano)
A lo devi fare riposare? Chef Mario)
Aspetta che sei fuori fuoco (Chef Rico)
Che novità!
Aggiungo il burro che si sarà sciolto. In
realtà c'era un pezzo che è sceso. Non temete se il piatto rimane sporco di burro, anzi fate così
Invece di mettervi subito a cucinare lasciate...
lasciate riposare per 20
minuti, non so perché, l'ha detto lo Chef, quindi
molto probabilmente sarà perché devono
rilasciare del glutine. Cosa fa il glutine?
Fa male ai... (Chef Mario). Celiaci.
Sono passati venti minuti, andiamo a
tirar fuori le nostre crepes dal frigo
Ragazzi scusate... io direi a questo punto di fare questo
tentativo, cosa abbiamo da perdere?
Non abbiamo credibilità, mai avuta
Quanto si potrebbe tenere al microonde?
Lui quanto la tiene? (Chef Mario)
Non la mette al microonde, lui è uno Chef
Mi prendo tutte le responsabilità di questa trovata
Vai vai vai è perfetta oh (Chef Rico). Poi entra là dentro e...
Nemica, nemica giurata del microonde. Ma non bisogna girarla? Secondo me è fallimentare questa roba
Ao grazie eh. Che scoperta! Devi farla da un lato e da un altro
Non credo proprio, non credo che funzioni così. Te hai quest'amore platonico per il
microonde inspiegabile. Non è platonico. Noi due ci baciamo spesso. Si vede meglio così
che ad occhio nudo,
guarda il tuo riflesso pure si vede (Chef Rico)
Dovrò fare delle pose. Oddio stanno facendo
delle bolle
E' diventata un tutt'uno con il piatto (Chef Mario)
Sembra cotta. E' crepes nel senso che crepi
se provi a mangiarla
Se qualcuno di voi ha mai provato a farle
al microonde mi faccia sapere qua sotto
qual è la tecnica, ma ho capito che
questa tecnica non funziona, quindi per
la prima volta all'interno di questo
canale proveremo a utilizzare il fuoco
Io provo pure a farla girare. Certo! Certo! Perché mica
sono nato ieri
Spostiamoci nella mia altra cucina.
Beh già è un altra cosa da vedere (Chef Rico). Mamma mia, posso dire...
ragazzi, liscia! La devi cuocere parecchio,
diciamo sotto per fare la giravolta eh
non so se alla scuola di microonde (Chef Rico)...
No alla scuola di danza me
l'hanno insegnato. Sei pronto?
Vai. Non ci credo!(Chef Rico). Ecco qua! Sarà fiero di te lo Chef (Chef Mario)
Potete continuare voi. Ne faccio altre
Ho fatto na frittata a sta botta ragazzi ve lo
dico. Io direi di iniziare intanto che si
cucina a mettere la nutella,
intanto che è ancora calda. Io non sono
mai stato bravo. A cucinare? (Rico). No a
sopportarti. Intanto lì dietro...(Rico). Aspetta aspetta
Ragazzi non mi va di spalmarlo...nono scusa cosi poca nutella? (Rico)
Me la mangio io questa. Questa non mi sembra
pazzesca.
Dai quella la mangia Gian...Mario
Chef Mario. Questa è la mia . Che cos'è questo? Non è più la mia (Rico)
Io moderato. Così ti va bene? Ti spalmo bene questa? Va
benissimo. Poi a quel porco di Rico
mettice il barattolo (Chef Mario)
Gu ma sei fort (Rico)...ma che cosa sta succ...
ma non capisco come faccio! Questa è bellissima(Mario). Mamma mia ragazzi. Grazie Guglielmo (Rico)
Allora Enrico. Guarda già come si vede la differenza (Mario)... la differenza fra me e te. Tu morirai. Presto!
Ragazzi è un fagottino. Eh qui ne esce un'altra.
Mi sa che dopo arriva Giunluigi (Rico)
Dovrebbe sbrigarsi altrimenti...
O quatro su quattro per adesso eh (Rico)
Guarda che s*****o. E' arrivato il momento o di fallire
miseramente o di fare il perfect
Ma non si mettono in teoria più strati di
nutella? (Rico) Cioè tra le gengive? Cucchiaio di
nutella, morso e cucchiaio di nutella.
Questo è un sorriso. Mi sa che me la mangio
Bellissima (Mario).
Mamma mia. Ma posso provare io? Vai
Oddio c***o. Mamma mia. Questo è un c******e (Mario)
Era bella questa. Vabbé è sempre bella, me la magno io. Vabbè la mangi tu?
Ci sta eh?! Si
Credo sia arrivato il momento di
assaggiare queste crepes e per la prima
volta in questa cucina,
preparate i vostri palati.. Enrico
Giammi. Proviamo. Fatemi sapere
Co la nutella dentro... so boni tutti? Eh so boni tutti.
Però per la prima volta hai superato l'insufficenza
E' buona è buona. Questo è un porco, altro che monoboccone. Ora dalle orecchie gli esplodono
Lasciamole ai commensali. Allora lasciamole a chi deve venì. No io basta. Tu afflitto eh?
Tocca dire che l'equilibrio di Chef Stefano si
sente in questo impasto. Non ho capito
se va male siete voi, se va bene è Chef
Stefano? Io non ho fatto niente. Ma se
invece le facessimo sparire di nascosto
quelle crepes? Non devono sapere tutti che
abbiamo fatto le crepes. Tanto lo sapranno troppo tardi. Ragazzi, venite qua
Eravamo pronti per finire. Io in realtà non me la
mangio una metà. Un terzo
Enrico tu prendila tutta. Quale volete?
Prendiamo questa che ce n'è di meno, tu prendi
questa e più ciotta. Mamma mia come fai oh!
C'è chi mette la nutella pure qua. Eh. Eh, te eri morto
Finalmente una ricetta che non fa venì l'emorroidi. Infatti non ha abbagliato nessuno oggi dei cani
E' vero. Coincidenze? Non
credo. Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
ricetta. Questo è il piatto finito, io
personalmente ho un problema perché
all'interno delle crepes metto solamente
la nutella ma fatemi sapere qua sotto
magari se avete delle alternative dolci
salate  alle quali io non ho mai
minimamente pensato né mai prese in
considerazione, mi sa che a volte ci metto
pure il mascarpone. A e poi sono io quello lì
che, cioè il male dentro la crepes? (Rico) Ti sei mangiato due crepes (Mario)
Come silenziarti. Che dire, grazie per i vostri consigli,
fatemi sapere che tipo di ricette vi
piacerebbe vedere all'interno di questo canale
ma soprattutto... questo crepes erano buone! Ma
soprattutto ci vediamo la prossima domenica
con un altro video. Ciao